well I know the word courage is a huge
thing for you and then you said that the
word has changed it's evolved what
encouraged initially mean to you and how
has it manifest well it's very
interesting
I mean soldiers don't even like the word
courage in their opinion their soldiers
and there's cowards but the word
courageous soldier the phrase courageous
soldier is completely redundant they're
one in the same thing in the minds of
soldiers I think there's a kind of raw
physical courage in combat or in other
situations I think young men are wired
for that and quite good at it I think
it's all product of evolution and I
think our species dependent on depended
on something like that and it's young
men you can see the same behavior in
primates also it's very clear this is
know so it came from an evolutionary
past but I think there's other forms of
courage as well his moral courage his
political courage and I think you know
basically courage courage means standing
for an ideal for a principle regardless
of the consequences there was an amazing
study done but comparing courage between
men and women men typically their
courage takes the form of physically
taking action running into the burning
building jumping into the surf to change
to save the child protecting their
girlfriend from bullets in a theater
where someone's shooting at them that
kind of thing women actually don't do
that very much certainly now if this men
are out well they let the men do it and
well they should wear women's courage
comes into play is is a really moral
courage and during World War Two there
were there were people in Europe who
were not Jewish right they were not in
danger from the Nazis and they would
hide Jewish families in their basements
or whatever things that would absolutely
get their whole get them killed
if the Germans found out about it and
often it was women the female heads of
households not the
man who were insisting on these things
it was a real moral courage that men
actually are a little bit more
ambivalent about so this I mean we're in
incredible species right humans and
there's those two very important forms
of courage they seem to be divided a
little bit by gender and I think both
are necessary for a safe and civil
society actually
you